ce soit on a une entrevue spéciale d'une
heure au programme puisque je suis en
compagnie de tonnes
après le petit génie derrière l'un des
plus grands succès de la bande dessinée
pour adultes le slasher mal cela showman
si c'est toute ma vie c'est une oeuvre
inspirante
je dois être honnête avec vous et vos
auditeurs je n'ai pas trouvé ma faim
encore on part ensemble un boîtier et ce
sera vraiment super amusant et très
instructif on va dormir dans des motels
ils sont ruraux et authentique
je croyais pas que saison doit exister
encore est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose ici
qui ravive ton inspiration ce pourrait
bien être la scène d'un massacre en
effet qu'est ce qui s'est passé on est
au milieu de nulle part il faut trouver
une solution
[Musique]
vous ne trouvez pas légitime
l'inquiétude que cette toxicité
culturels puissent pousser des
personnalité instable a basculé dans la
violence
j'ai dessiné quads et des milliers de
meurtres il peut arriver que l'un d'eux
ressemble à un véritable meurtre leur
pays de singly merde faut qu'on appelle
la police pour leur tiroir fière d'être
un tueur qui rôde et qui recrée les
meurtres mais bd qui se passe
tada dessinée ça
cet homme s'apprête à vous tuer
croate murray
[Musique]
mais qui images et tout ça